hi I'm Eric Voss and spider-man far from
home set up the future of Peter Parker
and the broader MCU and some of the most
exciting ways and not just because of
its bonkers post-credit scenes that had
grown men wetting themselves far from
home story is set the world rich with
detail Easter eggs and peripheral clues
at hint at secret background plans in
motion for future challenges to Spider
Man specifically the next spider-man
film may finally a symbol the sinister
six in the MCU now we have been waiting
for a sinister six movie for quite some
time
remember Sony's amazing spider-man 2
ended with a post-credits sequence that
hinted at a sinister 6 sequel that never
happened because those plans were
scrapped when they rebooted spider-man
as Tom Holland in the MCU there was some
speculation over the past year that far
from home could introduce these sinister
6 or maybe hinted their future in a
post-credits scene but didn't happen
well at least not explicitly I do think
that if you re watch far from home you
can definitely find evidence pointing to
the introduction of these sinister six
in the third Tom Hollands spider-man
whether it's titled home wrecked or home
sick homebound home to Badu spoiler
warning if you have not seen spider-man
far from home yet because I don't care
about ruining your life anymore
ok in the Marvel Comics the sinister six
consistency districts cuz it's hard to
say it consists of a rotating lineup of
spider-man villains with the originals
beam Doc Ock electro Kraven the hunter
Mysterio Sandman and vulture with pretty
much all the spider-man villains tagging
in and out throughout the years and I
would not be surprised if the MCU
sinister 6 mixes things up a bit
we know from spider-man homecoming that
vulture Adrian Toomes and Scorpion Mac
Gargan do exist in the MCU last seen in
prison with Gargan plotting revenge
against spider-man and tombs certain
about where he's sitting he did keep
Peters identity a secret which does
definitely complicate things now that
Jay jonah Jameson and Mysterio have
outed Peter to the public so with
vulture and scorpion that's one to two
potential sinister six members right
there and then of course there's
Mysterio now he did appear to die at the
end of far from home but there is
definitely plenty of evidence to suggest
he could have faked his death stay tuned
for a future episode on that if Mysterio
is still alive he and his team
could certainly lead an MCU sister six
that team might also include Dimitri
that was the driver who saved the part
of Nick Fury Maria Hills operation and
operation was based on scroll but if he
turns out to actually be working more
closely with Beck he could be revealed
as dmitriy smirnov aka the spider-man
villain the chameleon we also know from
far from home that Peter Parker has made
other enemies in the New York area and a
deleted scene Peter takes down the
Manfredi crime syndicate which in the
comics includes Silvio Manfredi aka the
villain Silvermane and one of the
gangsters spider-man strung up in that
deleted footage wears a leopard print
outfit leading me to speculate in the
past that he or she could be Kraven the
hunter beyond these six to seven
possible villains still part of
spider-man's world far from home
does hint at a few other possible
sources for threats if you're looking
closely before I continue thank you to
experience for sponsoring this breakdown
Experion lets you boost your credit
score's instantly for free by doing what
you're already doing like paying your
utilities and your cell phone bill like
up until now you pay those bills but you
don't really get credit for it now you
can now there's an easy way to get back
to a credit score that makes you feel
like a grown-up a higher credit score
can help you establish credit or get
access to preferred credit options used
to take months to improve your credit
scores but with Experian booster you can
improve your scores instantly most
people who boost C and increase greater
than 10 points people all across America
have already raised their credit scores
with Experian bust and you should too so
we invite you to take part in the boost
America movement today Experian boosts
can potentially help you establish or
increase your access to credit it's safe
secure and 100% free no credit card
required boost your FICO score instantly
for free boost is only available at
Experian com / new rock stars or click
on the link in the description ok if
you're looking closely at the background
a far from home you may have noticed an
interesting clue at Avengers tower in
the movie it appeared under construction
suggesting that after Tony Stark and
happy Hogan moved out of it in
homecoming some new occupant could be
redeveloping it and then in the final
sequence spider-man swings through a big
atrium that was built in the middle
floors of the tower suggesting that that
new occupant could have moved in and
settled one theory that I liked is that
Avengers tower could now be taken over
by Oscorp the company of Norman Ozma
the green goblin barber moma also
established a mysterious subplot
surrounding Flash Thompson if you watch
closely on the bus Peter uses Edith to
see what everyone's texting and way off
in the corner you can see that flash is
texting his mom mother I have not heard
from you or father in days and then at
the end of the film there's this
interesting shot of Flash's family
driver picking him up at the airport and
flash asks them if his mother came the
guy shakes his head and flash lowers his
head in disappointment so what's going
on here somebody said this is just a
joke but it this is a joke it's a very
weirdly understated and sad one in the
comics flash Thompson's father abuses
him and his mother I have a feeling that
this could be going in a different
direction
I got a suspicion that the same way that
they surprised in the reveal of Michelle
as MJ at the end of homecoming they
could do something similar with flash in
the next film and that flash could just
be a nickname perhaps his parents are
going through marital problems and that
he might take on his mother's surname at
the end of it a surname that could be
Osborn and that flash could be a
nickname for Harry and that his mother
could be revealed as a Norma Osborne
figure with this MC version swapping the
gender which could help balance out the
gender ratio of a future sinister six
now sure normally a group of criminals
probably wouldn't care about that kind
of thing but here's the thing folks the
sinister six might not necessarily be
seen as sinister consider a scenario
where thanks to Jay jonah Jameson and
the fake news of Mysterio's team the
public might see spider-man as the new
super villain that Mysterio Jameson want
him to be seen as what would happen next
well New Yorkers would probably want a
new team of superheroes to assemble just
like the Avengers did to confront this
spider-man menace with Jameson cheering
them on we could see a super 6 or a
stupendous 6 a savior 6 led by an Iron
Man 2.0 a resurrected Mysterio in each
of these super criminals winning over
the public as replacement Avengers which
would make it even more impossible for
spider-man to bring to light their true
sinister agenda comment down below with
your thoughts on this theory and follow
me on instagram and twitter at EA boss
and subscribe to new rock stars for
break down so theories of everything
Marvel thank you for joining me and if
it turns out that the whole thing with
Flash's parents really is just
depressing subplot my profound apologies
[Music]